Black Mirror is Infamous for cutting a
little too close to home in its various
dystopian settings however few episodes
have generated more Buzz than the
Cinematic mystery hated in the nation
we've all heard about situations where a
crowd is whipped into a frenzy sometimes
it's by a charismatic person at a Podium
and others it's just a bunch of angry
people crowded together with nowhere to
release their rage either way the
results are usually catastrophic with
people involved getting badly hurt or
killed hated in the nation proposes the
question what if this mob mentality can
be channeled through an Unstoppable
technology that can reach its victims
anywhere and any time this is where the
true Terror of this Black Mirror episode
comes in as social media and the 24-hour
news cycle expose us to new people to
despise daily it's easy to see how the
technology available in hated in the
nation could be a double-edged sword
after all the episode also depicts how
drones are being used to spy on the
populace the adi's ability to track is
also what makes them so deadly is they
can locate individuals via signals from
surveillance and cell phones still the
grizzliest aspect comes from the notion
that the popular vote determines who
should be the drone's next victim
furthermore the power to kill is
channeled through a twitter-like app
where users can apply a hashtag and have
their own say on who should die this
detail adds an extra degree of relevance
to viewers watching the show today
though it might seem a bit unhinged the
idea of wishing death on people you
don't know personally goes back
surprisingly far after all countless
political and economic systems
throughout history have been designed or
corrupted to the point where those at
the bottom have so little that they
naturally begin to Garner a visceral
hatred for the powerful and Wealthy okay
the government
we knew that already however what these
disenfranchised groups have never had is
a way to take out that frustration on
their target of choice this is how Black
Mirror changes things while even the
most frustrated Among Us are unlikely to
plot an assassination attempt or try to
start a civil war we might be inclined
to use something as simple as a hashtag
to vent some of our overflowing anger
lichen hated in the nation while some
might spurn the technology and opt out
from participating there are plenty more
who would embrace the ability to make
direct and permanent changes to society
without even leaving the comfort of
their homes furthermore there are others
teenagers and young adults in particular
who might just try it out for a lark
never really considering the
consequences of their actions as with
lots of real technology once this power
becomes widely accessible the next
challenge that arises is to decide
exactly who gets to regulate it and
which restrictions should be applied to
it
we see throughout hated in the nation
how the fervor of public outrage can
erupt seemingly out of nowhere and how
the response is sometimes largely out of
proportion to the actual act committed
by the Target for instance we have
far-right journalist Joe Powers mocking
the suicidal sacrifice of a disability
rights activist a rapper named Tusk who
insults one of his young fans and Clara
meets a young woman who poses for an
inappropriate photo at a war memorial
now it's easy to see why the public
would disapprove of all three but are
they all the same is calculated Menace
really the same thing as just making a
poor decision in a moment this seems to
be the point of hated in the nation as
technology like the adi's could exist
and has even been discussed by
scientists to solve the potential
Extinction of bees in the real world
however as with any scientific or
technological development a power like
this could easily be used for evil even
if it was only proposed to solve a
serious problem
social media was originally imagined as
a way for the user to reconnect with old
friends or co-workers meet new friends
and lovers or get their ideas out to a
wider audience in some ways the idea of
social media borders on the utopian when
you think of it like that however this
has been pretty far from the end result
what we have in much of the world today
is a reflection right out of Black
Mirror isolated groups with increasingly
disparate and divisive beliefs argue
with each other relentlessly or simply
disappear into their own Echo chambers
of like-minded individuals however when
a majorly divisive personality emerges
into the public sphere they could easily
become a target for this kind of attack
suddenly there's a million invisible
people all talking about how they
despise you take polarizing politicians
or celebrities who have been caught up
in a scandal at one time or another any
of these people could regularly and
easily become a real-life Target for
this kind of Technology if it actually
existed this is not to suggest that
there aren't plenty of people in these
categories who have said or done bad
things only that the notion that they
should be killed for these actions is a
very extreme response and one most
people would not want to see happen
unless perhaps they could do so safely
without the threat of arrest or
Consequences
the final revelation of the episode
comes when our protagonists attempt to
disable the Drone system and improper
Black Mirror fashion it goes horribly
wrong instead of shutting down the adi's
react by killing everyone who has ever
used the hashtag to wish death on
another the public hearing the detective
Chief Inspector Karen Park is at is in
response to this shocking National
tragedy still despite knowing that
Garrett's skulls was responsible for the
corruption of the Adis the villain
escapes largely unpunished to Simply
start again somewhere else or does he
hated in the nation caps things off with
an open-ended conclusion that sees
Park's Protege blue Coulson tracking
down skulls in a foreign country however
the episode ends before showing what
happens next and there is no
continuation of the story in the
remainder of the Black Mirror episodes
that have come since still what the
ending suggests is that Coulson might
choose to take vigilante justice on
skulls herself not only that but Park
immediately deletes the text after she
gets it suggesting that she may not only
support such an action but might even be
happy to help cover up any evidence of
the transgression she can the message
seems to be that once again those in
charge are happy to color Outside the
Lines regarding these types of
Technology but only if they can also
maintain control over them